it's officially monsoon season we know
during a thunderstorm rain can
fall very quickly that means the threat
of flash flooding bianca holman is in
henderson to show us
what's keeping your family safe
we're here at the pitman north detention
basin in henderson
this basin protects businesses roads and
thousands of homes across henderson and
in the southern highlands neighborhood
flash floods are dangerous and deadly so
local agencies are trying to raise
awareness to prevent deaths and injuries
flood channels flow into this large
basin holding water trash
and dirt the basin is built to for a
potential 100 year flood and even though
there's only a one percent chance of it
happening the regional flood control
district
is prepared no human interaction is
needed for this structure
to operate no need for a gate or switch
it's here
working all the time 24 7 365 days a
week it doesn't matter if it starts
raining at 2 am in the morning this
basin will be here
to protect the properties downstream so
i as the general manager of a flight
control district i really appreciate the
fact that i sleep better at night
knowing that these facilities are in
place
and protecting the community there are
plans to help protect older areas across
the valley
the national weather service and fire
department want to remind everyone to
use
caution when driving in the rain matter
of fact as little as six inches can
cause your vehicle to swerve
and 12 inches can cause your vehicle to
float
they also want to remind people if you
see a pool of water turn around don't
drown
and never play in the water flood
channels bianca holman 8 news now